es gibt es in der area 51 wir haben
einen möglichen heilung sweg gegen hiv
und eine revolutionäre entdeckung in der
planetenentstehung das sind drei der dem
jetzt endlich zum top news
der rosetta landeplatz hat einen namen
die landesstelle des filial enders der
mission rosetta heißt an gilt ja unter
8300 einsendungen wurde der name von den
verantwortlichen der europäischen
weltraumorganisation esa ausgewählt der
name hat will kia kommt von einer insel
im nil die 1980 der neue standort für
den tempel von william wurde seitdem
sechster august umkreis die raumsonde
rosetta den kometen 67 pdf gerasimenko
unter fünf möglichen landeplätzen hatte
sich die esa am 15 september entschieden
die zielregion ist vergleichsweise flach
und nur mit wenigen gesteinsbrocken
bedeckt das minilabor filet steht kurz
vor der landung auf dem kometen in sechs
tagen am 12 november soll die
landeeinheit der raumsonde rosetta auf
dem kometen aufsetzen revolutionäre
entdeckung in der planetenentstehung um
neugeborene sterne entstehen planeten
offenbar deutlich früher als bisher
angenommen
das schließen forscher aus chile
aufgrund von beeindruckenden bildern aus
dem all
welche die bislang detailreichsten
aufnahmen eines entstehenden
sonnensystems zeigen die dunklen ringe
und lücken die auf dem bild zu erkennen
sind stammen
mit großer wahrscheinlichkeit von
entstehenden planeten teilte die
europäische südsternwarte eso in
garching bei münchen mit die
staubscheibe die sich mit im sternbild
stier befindet und etwa 450 lichtjahre
entfernt von der erde ist demonstriert
die entstehung einer welt sterne bilden
sich aus kosmischen gas und staubwolken
in denen durch die gravitation
angetrieben die heißen kern
aufeinanderprallen und verschmelzen
die restliche wolke sammelt sich in
einer protoplanetaren scheibe um den
jungen sternen auf dieser brücke
entstehen durch das erneute
zusammenballen von materie dann also
jeden kometen und eben planeten die
größeren planetaren körpern die dabei
entstehen flügen spalten und ringe in
die scheibe wie es jetzt auch mit dem
radioteleskop alma beobachtet wurde
hiv selbstheilung also die heilung von
aids entschlüsselt der genetische
mechanismus der zwei männer vom hi-virus
galt hat wurde jetzt von
wissenschaftlern aus frankreich entdeckt
wie die wissenschaftler bekannt gaben
ist das phänomen der heilung von hiv das
ergebnis einer revolutionären
veränderung das dem zum abo beck soll
die viren dna so verändern dass die
viren nicht mehr in der lage sind sich
in den zellen des immunsystems zu
reproduzieren
die beiden männer seien kein einzelfall
teilten die französischen forscher mit 1
prozent der infizierten sei sogar von
natur aus in der lage den erreger so zu
unterdrücken dass er klinisch nicht
nachzuweisen sei auch die beiden männer
zeigten keinerlei symptome einer hiv
erkrankung da das erbgut des virus durch
das enzym abo beck verändert wurde
deshalb wurden sie auch nie behandelt
und wie genau dieser mechanismus
funktioniert und warum diese gruppe von
menschen in der lage war das virus
zurück zu halten war lange ein rätsel
die analysen der probanden erlaubnis das
im genom der patienten gefundenen virus
zu rekonstruieren so konnten die
wissenschaftler nachweisen dass der
erreger durch eine unterbrechung der
informationen aus den genen des virus
ausgeschaltet war
die beiden testpersonen der studie sind
weiterhin infiziert allerdings können
klinische tests den erreger nicht in
ihrem blut nachweisen
die forscher glauben dass dieser
spontane schritt in der evolution
möglicherweise der schlüssel zu einer
heilung von hiv ist es gibt in der area
51 im mysteriösen sperrgebiet area 51 in
der wüste von nevada sollen angeblich 18
freundlich gesinnte aliens für die usa
arbeiten das sagt jetzt der mittlerweile
verstorbene raumfahrtingenieur beugt
buschmann in einem youtube-video die
aliens hätten graue haut große augen und
telepathische fähigkeiten
er will auch mit den außerirdischen
zusammengearbeitet haben dass es die
militärbasis area 51 tatsächlich gibt
darüber gibt es keinen zweifel in dem
zwei 30-minütigen film erzählt beugt
buschmann das unglaubliche geheimnis
seines lebens er hat dort gearbeitet
eigenen angaben zufolge habe als
wissenschaftler für die us rüstungsfirma
loket martin dort gearbeitet insgesamt
26 patente im bereich luft und raum
fahrt angemeldet glaubt man seinen
berichten habe er sogar gemeinsam mit
den aliens an einem ufo gearbeitet und
versucht es zu reparieren
ein oder zwei de und seien etwa 230
jahre alt gewesen so buschmann das
aussehen der außerirdischen beschreibt
er wie folgt die wesen haben sehr lange
finger füße bei denen die zehn lieber
fröschen zusammengewachsen sind und
kommen vom planeten find two mehr
besonders hebt er die telepathischen
fähigkeiten der elends hervor sie hätten
ihm erklärt dass wenn einer der helden
es eine frage habe er nur an sie denken
müsse um von den anderen eine antwort in
seinem kopf zu hören doch der
wahrheitsgehalt der geschichte bleibt
zweifelhaft auf der plattform red dot
com hat ein user bereits nachgewiesen
einer der gezeigten aliens ist nur eine
große spielzeugpuppe ebola resistent
durch spezielle gene unsere gene
bestimmen möglicherweise ob wir das
ebola-virus überleben oder nicht das
haben forscher der universität von
washington in den usa in einer studie
mit labormäusen herausgefunden
demnach gibt es zwei besondere gene die
entscheidend für die genesung nach einem
befall oder die immunität gegen den
aggressiven erreger sind die
forschergruppe mahnt allerdings noch zur
vorsicht inwiefern solche gene auch beim
menschen vorhanden sind müsse erst noch
überprüft werden
die amerikanischen wissenschaftler haben
mäuse mit dem ebola virus infiziert der
die aktuelle solche verursacht hat und
die auswirkungen der erkrankung
beobachtet
dabei sind die unterschiedlich stark
ausgeprägten symptome aufgefallen die
forscher vermuten nun dass die gene der
mäuse für eine resistenz oder eben eine
abschwächung der symptome verantwortlich
sind
genauer gesagt sind es gene die man
aktivieren des immunsystems und dem
reparieren der blutgefäße informiert
sind
in der studie berichten die forscher
dass etwa 70 prozent der mäuse symptome
des ebola-virus zeigten und mehr als die
hälfte von ihnen dann an blut und leber
problemen gestorben ist rund ein fünftel
der mäuse überlebte bei den toten mäusen
fanden die wissenschaftler zwei gene die
kaum aktivität zeigten und so die
blutgefäße und dicht machten die
zerstörung der blutgefäße ist eben ein
typisches symptom des ebola erregers das
führte zu einem austritt der weißen
blutkörperchen die angrenzenden zellen
entzündeten sich und sterben ab was zu
organversagen führte und schlussendlich
zum tod
die überlebenden
hatten eine erhöhte aktivität der gene
die für die produktion weißer
blutkörperchen sowie die reparatur der
blutgefäße zuständig sind auf den
menschen kann dieses ergebnis aber noch
nicht übertragen werden
das forscherteam merkt an dass die
äußeren einflüsse auf ebola patienten
nicht berücksichtigt wurden dazu zählt
unter anderem die art und qualität der
krankenpflege ebenso würden sich die
ergebnisse auf infektion bei mäusen
beziehungen könnten aufgrund der
komplexen genetischen kombination des
menschen nur bedingt übertragen werden
wir wissen nicht welche gene es in
menschen sind sagt michael katz
malgruppe mikrobiologe und co autor der
studie
aber wenn wir herausfinden welche gene
es exakt in der maus sind haben wir ein
hinweis den gesamten verlauf und jede
menge infos zur ebola epidemie gibt es
in dieser play ist ihr da kriegt man sie
sehen will tägliche news rund um das
thema ebola und die wissenschaft gibt es
eine app und lockt dafür hier klicken
allerdings immer in der video
beschreibung und somalia haben wir bald
eine effektive heilmethode gegen hiv was
es mit ebola ist es gerechtfertigt da
für tierversuche zu machen diskutiert
ist wie immer mit mir in den kommentaren
ansonsten bis dann ja dann